they give you a function like it's just
one big long connective question the
endpoint is sketchy which is
unsurprising and we're going to use what
we know about calculus to sort of chew
our way through it okay let's begin with
the first part they simply ask you
what's the domain of this function
what's the domain is now that's a bit of
a it's a bit of a mouthful just in
itself so I want you to remember because
classic mathematician strategies
simplify the question first if I just
gave you this function what would you
like which very few leaders what would
you say is the domain of that function
ya X is positive that's all I want right
because as we remember you've got the
asymptote there at zero right and
there's a shape I always think of domain
in terms of shape rather than obvious
function that function
some people just remember our log
functions only take positive values if
that works for you and that's great but
I kind of always have a picture bucket
so we this about the domain for this
function we can take that and apply it
to this right what we want is that piece
in there the X right or the function
inside that we take the log of we want
that to be probably okay so therefore
I'm going to say for Part A to get the
domain what I want is for x squared on X
plus 1 to be greater than zero and you
can throw it to like say for example we
will get to the point where we can graph
this none that you would ever be
required to do that as an extension
wants to but just think about this for a
second we could do this like if I asked
you for the domain of this what would
you conclude about this know what we
just set you up yeah I just want all the
parts of that curve that are positive
right so we know what that curve looks
like on it because you're away but we're
getting this kind of shape so therefore
good morning the log of this graph would
be defined from not 180
dreamers just agrees to buy 40 right and
so on okay so the principle is not that
crazy
okay you can apply in all sorts of ways
even when it looks like they're not even
gonna stop okay so we get this what
would you do just not solving this
inequality any suggestions yeah okay
sure a great strategy that I could take
key is that I don't want it to you with
this something of it domain up because
it's gonna be a hyperbola it was kinda
gross right so I can multiply both sides
by X plus 1 all squared right why do I
have to square it again
what's a bit of significance of that
okay good yeah it has to do with the
sign of what I'm multiplying by and more
importantly like the direction of the
inequality
oh yeah you'll notice you this I am I
have been to buy hits at 0 that's
because X plus 1 squared times 0 is so
so that's a good reason why like that's
another sort of feather you have for why
you want to do it by that could spit
however by saying this from the first
line to the second line I've lost some
information out of the question right
something is is not equivalent between
these two what's not good because the
first one has the fraction built into it
right I can see by the way from there
the X could be negative one yeah but
what I'm going to this line because the
fractures disappear just by making this
line a cartel so I've got to say that
and that's really significant because
that affects the domain right ok so now
that I've got this this is a cubic it's
a fairly simple it has well depending on
the credit it's on your two or cream
roots what are they
zero negative one right zero negative
one is really a double root at zero yeah
so just really quickly because what I
want is where is this thing right let's
just do a quick sketch right around the
cubic because it's a are the leading
coefficient is positive right it's going
to start down the bottom and it's gonna
go up to the top so I'm getting this
kind of shape are you happy with that
dude and that's just wanna keep it looks
like this my double root that I was
expecting okay so with another color
which parts of this am i interested in
that are greater than zero
yeah yeah these parts okay very good
okay so what our buddy is tower let's
take this high status this first part
I'm gonna go left to right if I go left
is negative 1x 0 yep and the second part
is that you spread fear and of course I
have to say or what and or a column
which don't mean anything why do I have
to say for yeah yeah there's no value of
x that can satisfy both of these
inequalities at the same time here
mutually exclusive so there you go
there's my isit is the domain by the way
it's worth mentioning
we at the beginning I said like what
strategy screw you take to go in and
solve this and we opted to multiply turn
this into a polynomial we didn't have to
do that was not mandatory we could have
gone from the first line right and you
can think roughly about what the shape
of this thing is I just think about it
without networking your ballot what do
you know about this crap
think about it what's all those obvious
things that you can see there's two
obviously there's an acetone from the
denominator at x equals
right there's an intercept where is it
give you a clue my sentence in the water
it's going to be at x equals zero right
so at x equals zero y is your son going
through the origin like that okay and
then I'm guessing now remember what I'm
interested in is domain right it's done
mate
so therefore because I didn't design per
blah it looks like it's gonna have a
oblique asymptote I don't really care
what people guess what is that that's
irrelevant to me why it says there is
one so I get the general shape see that
oh it doesn't take that much imagination
to see this with more familiarity if you
ever look at basically all okay that's
roughly what I'm going to get but if
this comes to you quicker they just go
for it you're still gonna get this I
hope you can see this you can read off
here exactly the same you see this for
negative 1 to 0 and then see where it
was okay right now let's have a look at
the derivative now just for the sake of
brevity I haven't written on there they
actually seem sure that the derivative
is blah blah blah so there's no function
right now human being in its current
state in its current state what kind of
knowledge do I need to know in order to
differentiate this yeah okay number one
I need chain rule because I've got a
function of a function what else do I
need to know okay good so I'm gonna have
to do this guy in here because of chain
rule and that's a that's a question is
it not so I'm going to need the question
room and then of course it's a policy
now general question rule both things
that up you know they're gonna make
these quite complex particularly
question rule right now I can't
differentiate this into question room it
took me one two three four lines four
lines okay which is not too bad for
words is not unreasonable however I'm
just gonna write down the first line of
it for you just so you can see why I'm
not going to go down that path as they
say so let's think about this
okay I'm just gonna write that the first
I'm not gonna bother actually competing
it as you're see why in a second chain
rule tells me I do the inside and then
object outside inside the downside so to
the inside shall we
it's poor shape it looks to me like they
do - by this you fee - all over V
squared don't do it right
does it look okay I just did in my head
so may have written an arrow to yours I
think that's it right there's the inside
and then I do the outside I usually
write that as f - on earth could
subtraction I'm trying to effectively so
I'm gonna say / and this F front of
squared long did you see why I don't
like this way of doing it I mean not to
mention the fact that the reason why I'm
pretty confident on this is because I
did it not that long ago so I have done
this right but this part in fear boy how
many times have you come up with an
error or guarantee like why doesn't my
thoughts in that job and quotient rule
is responsible okay cuz question is hard
there's so much you have to have in your
brain it's a very error-prone metal
sometimes you kind of wait but when you
can't avoid it you should so how do I
avoid
it's fun photography then you've got
product rule but it's still gonna end up
things like the net effect will be the
same what else can we do this
yeah good in here right I can use locals
to break this into it
right and in fact it becomes even easier
once I do this so I've got log of x
squared and I because it's division I
subtract the other logs right this is
already a massive improvement massive
has occurred I could do a bit better
than this he's like it's good right
yeah use the power loss so this is going
to be 2 log X minus okay that looks much
more manageable okay um but that
question will incite I do have to use
chain a little bit hardly like Bailey
right so at this point now I'm going to
depreciate that looks to me like it's
gonna be 1 X minus 1 while I'm an
imposter okay boy I hardly even have to
think right now admittedly what this
does mean in addition is I have to get a
common denominator so I'll add these
together but I think we generally agree
adding algebraic fractions substantially
easier that day question rule right so
this is 2x plus 2 we subtract 10x you're
gonna get X plus 2 and I believe this is
the result you're required to prove okay
so we had to do like look at this
remember I said to you before this
question rule it should be four lines
right but they're for hard lines these
are this took me an extra line but they
were all easy like they were quite
readable in terms
[ __ ]